coming up at 6 25 on your friday morning
how about finding a cute little
neighborhood
near the 95 in the northern 215 beltway
come on we're going
centennial bowling so in our in your
neighborhood stories about centennial
hills earlier this week the eight news
now drone flew over this two block long
street called norman rockwell lane
businesses
residential at one end a park at the
other a mixed use construction going on
some people said hey nate that's great
but where exactly is the village at
centennial springs well
allow me to be your siri google with
these hopefully easy directions
from us 95 you go north east on durango
and hang it right at the first light
that's farm road
now after the cvs and the dotties on the
right keep your eyes peeled because
there's norman rockwell lane hiding
in plain sight got a lot to unpack there
three restaurants another one on the way
numerous small businesses that includes
the cool bicycle shop we feature the
puzzle
and game shop next door and the brand
new penny farthing antiquing
collectibles store on the next plot
we have links to those earlier stories
and the online version of this story at
eightnewsnow.com like traffic than
driving you crazy and you know what
there are dozens of hidden gem
neighborhoods all over the valley with
pandemic restrictions loosening and if
you're comfortable
you might consider exploring this
vibrant part of the world that we call
home buckle up drive carefully and
please put down that phone if there's
something driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at
news now dot com